[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to cultural appropriations
[Music]
hi i'm tim the vaxman mclizer ceo of
lyser pharmaceuticals this is my
assistant albortion
hell is actually a survivor of rape and
incest his parents were going to have
him aborted but decided not to thanks
how are you feeling today good
i don't think so tim
great abortion
as you were
i know that many of our clients are
upset about the roe vs wade overturning
but i have good news if you've taken any
of the vaccinations or boosters
recommended by celebrities or other
people on the internet having a baby is
going to be the least of your concerns i
assure you for those of you that are
worried you can still get pregnant we
have a brand new product just for you
it's a brand new abortion vaccine
it'll make sure
abortion
the wrong label is on this box
the lies are abortion vaccine just take
a bunch of these and you'll be sterile
and the best part about this abortion
vaccine is they're already available
where our other vaccinations are in the
very same syringes unbeknownst to even
the people that work there so just go in
ask for those and they'll give them to
you two of them three of them they're
free you just ask and you can have them
so
for proof that it works
here's some testimonials i got to tell
you before i had all the vaccines and
all the boosters i was always worried
about getting pregnant my husband and i
would even have to wear condoms but now
i don't risk it at all i can just worry
about what meals i have to make my
husband goes at it raw and sometimes he
brings his friends over and we have
adult parties just starring me and then
afterwards we have coffee and they'll go
do you want me cream and i go i think
i've had enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
oh
that's soup
minestrone
that's bad i like a good italian wedding
soup in the morning
ahoy everybody and welcome to louder
with crowder with dave
there it is all right there it is worked
on that for an hour yes i did
my coordination skills not very good but
practice makes almost perfect
anyway welcome to the show uh we're
gonna have a very very big show today
and remember if we're thrown off of
youtube you can catch us on rumble
anywhere you find podcasts and of course
check us out on mug club on the blaze
and you know subscribe yeah yeah you get
a you get a mug and you get lots of fun
after the show where we don't have to be
so uh censored um yeah and that's even
so much censored in a way i got i just
realized that was there
how dare you here
they're not a sponsor the lawsuits will
follow that's fine no big deal
so will area 51
all right it doesn't exist dave what are
you talking about no it's not real not
real well they told us they were aliens
you know like
2020 and we were like we don't care
that's how bad 2020 was they're just
like they were like yeah aliens yeah
whatever and i've seen them get bigger
first to fry no big deal no big deal uh
well let's introduce everybody because
we're already starting it up gerald a
how are you sir good morning ahoy i'm
i'm doing i'm doing fantastic thanks for
asking yeah did i ask didn't ask how are
you why didn't you ask how's the new
baby baby's fantastic sleep is getting
better but it's still hard to come by
i've learned that you just shouldn't
price sleep in life you don't get it
early you don't get it late and then you
don't get it when you have kids and so
i'm just like ah screw it have you tried
shaking the baby
only enough
oh yeah just enough to make sure he
sleeps well of course yeah just saying
this is advice i have not advice at all
make sure you shake it just enough no
make sure it's alive to get a good
night's sleep there's a difference
between rocking and shaking yes yeah
shake until the noise is stopped
no none of these things are true except
what i said yeah shake it until you can
take the college fund back all right
so
i didn't want to give up my
room anyway no but congratulations of
course and then uh choking now and how
you doing back from maui yep good
morning good morning freshly married oh
yeah and then we got uh the new man
hangs out with the sexy ninja turtles uh
casey bones how are you good morning
good morning i had to think of a new one
it was either that or i gotta think of a
new one or the uh case of bass i like
that you like that one case of
all right
and of course uh tim the tool man how
are you doing today morning sir uh one
of my favorite people on earth uh please
welcome crawdaddy oh thank you david how
are you he switched it up on me today
last time that's right
yeah i was over here and the way i think
you're over there moved over yeah well
you guys can
we could switch right now if you want i
think it's good you're gonna do musicals
see how it goes i can sing please don't
you know
and of course uh you hear them and i
know you love them and you're glad to
have them back quarterback
hey
thanks for having me back i appreciate
it how are you i'm good and how's the
new little one good he's solidifying
i've been doing the shake method too yes
and before he was kind of like you know
really floppy yeah that was kind of
solidifying it's nice i did that
they tend to tighten up a little bit
yeah yeah when he's he's seven got a
real stutter
it's training
so
it's training garrett saw the shake
weight and he's like why i have a kid i
have yeah
i've been working out with vettel yeah
that's totally fine my first interesting
aside was your casey reference the ninja
turtle guy the baseball bet casey jones
jones he went to school with john and
stephen
at the same school
the imaginary actual guy
he didn't pay money for this cartoon
oh yeah the guy from the original 1980
or 1990 was it it was 1990 just famous
alumni really was the guy who played
casey jones
where are they now yeah that's pretty
cool yeah you guys know knew a lot of
celebrities stephen has a picture with
john candy oh yeah you know how lucky
that is
that's a great picture too it's good
they kind of had to hire canadians when
they went up there to make cheap films
so yeah we got to hire the locals but
john candy that's like the
the king greatest of all
i think of all comments and he was
killing it then everything he did was a
hit i love him yeah you got you got a
picture with him at peak john candy yeah
there was well there was really no
non-peak john candy that's true he
didn't live long enough to have you know
no peek no that mean there was terrible
his last movie was
uh
not good uh that was this wagons
really right
not not horrible but not well i mean
compared to comedies of now is brilliant
uh but compared to his other body of
work is honestly right it was the lesser
candy
lesser candy yes indeed but he crossed
all lines though he they were little
kids when they met him yeah his staff
was trying we gotta go we gotta go we
don't and he said hey i'm hanging out
with steven and jordan here give me a
few minutes you know that's incredible
they just felt so yeah it's incredible
you know he's six three four four
hundred pounds he's larger than life
right so literally yeah i read his
biography and there's just people were
telling him to quit smoking he's like
yeah it'll stunt my growth i'm really
worried about it
yeah
shouldn't he be telling me to smoke yes
so we can reverse this trend yeah i
don't think he cared trying to shrink
yeah
well let's talk about this we're going
to have a lot of interesting topics on
the show today and of course the
question of the day
let me throw that to you we'll be
getting to uh the bts visit to the white
house a little bit uh later in the show
but since we missed aapi heritage month
which ended yesterday sadly what
uh that is what is that asian american
pacific islander i think is what i was
just talking about when i asked the very
same question
i thought also like the rock yes
i thought it was a retirement magazine
yes
i thought it was just more letters at
the end of the lgbtq yeah i thought we
were just adding they got to keep adding
them
aapi plus heritage month
write it
but honestly you know what's your
favorite asian uh contribution to
america i honest question there's so
many uh i like uh i like rush hour rush
hour is good yeah yeah for sure
it's still good yeah i still like it
still jackie chan
yeah chris tucker but it's not as good
yeah it's not as good i like the movie
old boy i suggest uh go home and watch
that family friendly
[Laughter]
it's a story about an old man i'm
guessing
yeah it's just coming to grips with his
age there's there's no it's a fun twist
at the end and you go wow what yeah
heart warming
it's a great father don't watch the josh
brolin one art or do
back to back whatever you want whatever
you start with josh
yeah and with the original sound yeah
fine film
fine family friendly film very family
friend i watch it with my kid once a
week
i think it's why he doesn't sleep
uh also you can join steven and i uh
we're gonna be on tour you can check us
out at uh our website and then you can
also check me out
uh i'll be at grand junction uh colorado
the night before our tour uh
june 17th
at the mesa theater i'll be with uh
maxwell hughes who is formerly of the
lumineers he's going to be doing some
music with me and of course matt
mcclowery and then the next night you
can see us in colorado springs
uh myself uh of course matt mclaury and
steven and i assume
thomas finnegan might be making a
special appearance wow so yeah when i
hear grand junction i just want to say
what's your function right i know i i
always looked at i didn't know it was a
place
you're like wait this town's real yes
this isn't one of those spaghetti
western towns they stood up for a minute
it sounds like it's a fake yeah they
just put it up is it near colorado
springs is it no it's like six hours oh
wow yeah yeah it's pretty far i wanted
to make sure there wasn't like a lot of
overlap when we
did that yeah because you want people to
drive a little bit but not too far
yes
and i kind of wanted to do something a
little different like tossing because i
like the lumineers so i wanted to toss
in like one of the original guys who's a
fan of the show
so i i don't know why he's not in the
band i'm going to guess conservative but
i i don't know it happens you know who
knows
now we all know that you know that would
never happen to a band no you know
mumford and sons i don't think it would
ever never happen no nobody cares about
politics inside the music industry
all right
it's the first day of pride month so uh
here's a pair of drag queen twins to
tell us
how to be a good queer ally
bad advice with sugar and spice how to
be a gay allies goodness
only refer to us as your gay best friend
remember we only respond to you hi gay
step two use this as a prop or accessory
we're clearly only useful for gossiping
shopping and telling you that you look
pretty
step three make sure to go to gay pride
and wear your love is love t-shirt all
while staying with your homophobic
transphobic misogynistic woman hating
trump loving boyfriend
and that was bad advice but sugar and
spices
[Music]
oh dear wow i would do sugar first
i think they received a lot of bad
advice in their life
[Laughter]
wear a rainbow maga hat and confuse
everyone are you saying they're passable
you know who i am no i'm just distracted
by how like their voices are just
gusting
so garrett they're you know that and
also untalented well that too so yeah
that as well it does sound like the
lunch lady it does yeah you want you
want some more mashed potatoes i got
some advice for you yes yeah don't i
sound like a good broad yeah you're a
good ally
here's the mashed potatoes just coughing
in there by the way it was i would never
call that person gay i would never
assume no that wouldn't be the first
time i never yeah i never assumed that
drag queen necessarily means gay though
no i don't i didn't used to yeah no i
have no idea i'd be thoroughly confused
but i wouldn't call them gay i don't
know but no one will ever get it right
it's the whole no matter how long this
plays out it cannot be fixed like
rolling the dice it's the men that's why
any time that it happens with me i'm
like i just got to be like oh i had no
idea that's right
eddie murphy yeah you know i was just i
was what huh
i was just giving her a ride home how
was i able to tell in broad daylight
i thought it was a woman
that had a penis because i was told i
didn't need to be a bigot
i just didn't know these things happened
i was like thralled by his her mind
inside melrose at like 3 p.m and he's
like i was simply yeah
it's like can you imagine that even just
gave people rides home and i love eddie
murphy but
i get it you were with a lot of people
and you wanted to stop a little bit into
the danger zone
right in the edge
oh my god yeah well
let's talk about this
thank you speaking of you can move on
things that shoot
i don't know what that means joe biden
is a gun expert did you guys know that
oh yeah yeah yeah i mean i wouldn't let
him handle one more of a shotgun expert
speaking to reporters uh on the white
house on monday biden had some
interesting comments about nine
millimeter rounds they weren't extremely
intelligent that brings us to this week
in biden wait if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump then you ain't black and they
[Music]
so the idea of these
high caliber
weapons
is
the constitution the second amendment
was never
i mean if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for me or trump then
you ain't black
hey guys i think we know he's going to
say stupid stuff let's have him take
questions exclusively in front of a
helicopter
i think my brain is just melting on the
inside i love the little duck tail he
has in the back of his like it's an
interesting hairstyle it is it's it's
like he's gonna try for a mullet
you know what i think he's going after
the donald trump look he oh you're right
he's gonna comb it over look what i do i
can do this little thing yeah it's not
it's not what donald trump's doing it's
this is my thing yeah yeah he's gonna
have his own
but one day it's just gold
it just starts slowly gets to where
golden as it goes around we're talking
about it's always been this color every
there's gold that it gets the economy
starts getting better
we start recovering like what
keep his hair
he was kind of making the case for why
we use nine millimeter wasn't he
i thought that was the whole purpose
i couldn't hear over the middle of the
night to do harm i couldn't so he was
actually damaged yeah right by accident
he is a gun expert well can you imagine
being the secret service agent standing
over there hearing this and going oh my
gosh
because you know they know about this
stuff like yeah yeah joe that's right a
nine millimeter will rip the entire lung
out of a human body yeah you know
you see the secret service agent throw
his gun and be like all right i'll use
karate how's that
fine let's see how that hurts
he couldn't pick like a 45
caliber and he said nine millimeter
oh good calculated i don't think he
knows what it is he's like 22 yeah they
wouldn't hunt against a trash can
outside of school yeah nine millimeter
yeah yeah
over the lung ripper rider thing i freak
out if i accidentally put the magazine
in with my practice rounds like oh
don't want that one we want the one that
does the most damage in there yeah
i would like to hang out but when i
punch holes in people
well that brings us to gerald no stuff
i really think my stinger should be
better that's so good no it's not that's
running lobbying for a better
i think i think it's the best singer in
this it is the show the best stinger
i've ever seen
i love it who's running
[Laughter]
we should have people vote right now
tell us what you think in the chat and
really yeah hit the like button if you
like
stingers yeah if you if you like gerald
stinger please like and comment right
now
and tell us what you like about it
[Laughter]
don't forget to mention the greek
columns yeah yes fantastic i appreciate
that
all right so joe biden i don't know if
you guys saw this uh released his plan
to fight inflation thank god he's been
uh delaying that just a little bit but
he did it on tuesday he dressed it in an
op-ed that he wrote for the wall street
journal entitling it
my plan for fighting inflation
my plan is to address inflation
starts with a simple proposition
respect the fed respect the fed's
independence get out of here which i
have done and will continue to do
my job as president is not to
uh nominate highly not only nominate
highly qualified individuals
for that institution but to give them
the space they need to do their job
i'm not going to interfere with their
critically important work
the fed has two responsibilities one
full employment two stable prices
chair paul and other leaders of the fed
have noted at this moment they have a
laser focus on addressing inflation just
like i am
and with a larger complement of board
members now confirmed
i know we'll use those tools and
monetary policy to address the rising uh
prices for the american well the white
chair is ballsy
he's fighting inflation with more
inflation
no i'm not jiu-jitsu i love what he did
his first step in fighting inflation was
blaming somebody else for inflation
hey i will make sure that they can do
their job and fight inflation trust
that's what's all beds
i love that that's that's that's a
pretty bad point but the other two
points that
he outlines in his op-ed were equally
horrific and uh the second one was make
things affordable by boosting capacity
and production right so everybody is
saying that right now the supply chain
issues are part of the problem and
that's the reason we have some of the
issues with higher prices the economy is
opening back up and we could never have
foreseen that the economy was going to
open up even though when i ran for
president i said we'll open up the
economy
great idea yeah and then to come out and
blame oil and gas prices on only putin
when those things were going up in the
first day in office he got rid of the
keystone pipeline he approved nordstrom
2 and he's done everything that he can
to make it harder on american companies
to produce more oil because he wants to
go green i got it he released energy or
some oil reserves globally by the way
that accounted for i think two days
worth of consumption in the united
states so that's obviously going to fix
the problem for people still record high
gas by the way so yeah 48 hours of gas
is pretty solid yeah it's fantastic yeah
yeah that'll solve everything uh but in
case you were worried he also is making
sure that we approve tax credits for
clean energy which will obviously solve
this problem tomorrow as well right so
that's step two of his plan to fight
inflation step three
sounds weird okay just hear me out
continuing to reduce the budget deficit
because he is super excited right now
that the cbo came out and said that he's
going to reduce the budget deficit by
1.7 trillion dollars and that's that's
fantastic right because everybody's like
oh that's a lot of money the cbo
actually says that after this next year
it's going down to one trillion dollar
deficit right
dave
if you had a thousand dollars in debt
last year you spent a thousand more than
you made and then this year you only
spent 500 more than you would that be a
win
uh no so let's say we're talking in
trillions right
why don't we just use made-up numbers at
this point
like i don't know like 1.7 trillion you
could be like a zillion jillion and
you'd be like that's fine that's about
it it's close to trillion guys i'm doing
a good job that works kind of by a good
i love that because garrett brought up a
good point that's progress bring up this
next this overlay uh a2 here about the
cbo's budget projections are 1.6
trillion dollars
from 23 through 32 2023
just for comparison wow
1.6 trillion dollars as a deficit would
be higher than we've ever had in history
other than covid as a deficit so here's
his play i don't know much but i know
bar graphs that doesn't look good that
bar graph he's looked drastic right we
reduced the rise just at the end yeah
the covet-sponsored deficit that we had
because we printed money and acted like
nothing was going to happen that was bad
for the economy after doing that but
don't worry we reduced it to about the
same level as it has been at our other
peak highs but next year we're going to
be at a new record high for normal times
outside of covet and that's part three
but it gets a little bit better here he
also wants to and i'll read the quote
end the outrageous unfairness in the tax
code that allows a billionaire to pay
lower rates than a teacher or
firefighter oh my god which always
pisses me off let's just go back and ask
how much elon paid what was it in 2020
or 2019 11 billion dollars in to income
tax the highest level and by the way the
reason that this happens if you guys
don't know this it's because most people
that are in the billionaire class don't
make their money from a paycheck they
make it from risking their finances in a
business or an investment where they
could lose every single thing or they
could make some money and if they do
they pay a lower rate because we want
them to do that you are at zero risk
unless you get fired of losing your
paycheck there's no risk and so
therefore you pay a higher income tax
rate that's what they do every single
time bernie sanders says those things
and take a look at this other quote from
biden because i think this is really one
of the game changers here
he says
in relation to the monthly job creation
he wants you to get a different
understanding of what the norm should be
he's basically preparing you for failure
rather if average monthly job creation
shifts in the next year from current
levels of you know 500 000 or something
maybe going down to closer to 150 000 it
will be a sign that we are successfully
moving into the next phase of recovery
i love it
because this kind of job growth is
consistent with a low unemployment rate
in a healthy economy so essentially what
joe biden did just to recap is said it's
the fed's fault basically we're going to
fix things by clean energy tax credits
you know it's russia's fault and then he
basically said billionaires need to pay
more money and oh by the way when the
numbers look really bad don't worry i've
already told you that's the new normal
thank you joe biden
and that what adult it's unreal it's
gonna turn out you know when you see a
penny on the ground you're like i gotta
pick that up it's dirty that's gonna be
like five dollar bills yeah yeah
amazing we're gonna be burning dollar
bills to stay warm
just wiping your ass with him it's like
why this is the whole plan right now
it's
i can't i can't wait to remember it's so
ridiculous oh it's like oh yeah you see
your hand rotting off yeah that's we're
recovering that's recovering we're
getting better getting better man is
there medicine for it no we're not dead
we haven't more rot though yeah this man
has bathed in [ __ ] and spin for so
long yeah he can't possibly know the
truth he just now so jump in there don't
understand this doesn't make any sense
at all and he's the guy that everybody's
looking to to fight record high
inflations and he's touting record high
budget
think his handlers deficits
gerald wouldn't you think his handlers
would put out something you know
somewhat intelligent i think his
handlers are just as stupid as he is
yeah yeah yeah i agree
i saw these guys making the rounds on
all the sunday shows saying we have low
unemployment right now i think they said
record low unemployment i'm not sure if
that's accurate but low unemployment
right now people have less debt and they
have more savings than they've had so
these are really good things these are
strong things compared to other
countries who are doing worse and i'm
like
are you looking at the guys predicting a
recession saying that every time that
this has happened in the last 40 years
we've seen a recession within the next
two years i think larry summers said
that
recently on those talk shows are you
looking at the record high budget
deficit that we will have other than the
two coronavirus years are you looking at
those statistics because by the way the
previous record was barack obama when
you were vice president
of the united states sorry he's the
current former vice president president
i mean i've spoken earlier and i'm
kamala harris president harris i'm very
sorry for saying that absolutely so but
that he doesn't really have any kind of
a plan and it's shown and no he tries to
act folksy and say i understand what gas
prices do and i understand what grocery
prices do you mention the table
exactly
but then he pivots to blaming everybody
else and deflecting responsibility
because at the end of his statement he
said i've done all i can
now it's time for congress to act
yes one more person what a leader the
bucket or pass the buck too so he kicked
the bucket sorry freddie and slipped i
thought the buck stopped here
that's where the buck stopped i thought
it was there never but he's like no but
i mean i meant there over over there the
feds no well that's what you want in a
leader is blaming everyone else yeah
that's solid yeah and that has been
gerald no stuff
guys
i didn't hear that part the first time
it's even better this time i hate all of
you i'm better this time i mean i love
you but not really guys we know you're
not gay-ish
why the ish
it's not exactly a ringing endorsement
you and i have secrets no we don't what
yes we do we don't don't lie
go ahead 69 dudes thank you bill and ted
yeah classic
however you saw this yesterday i'm i was
excited about it my favorite uh k-pop
boy band
oh yeah yes bts also known as uh bang
the slot visits the white house is that
real no oh on but bts's i think it
stands for like big
tiny
something i'm gonna i'm gonna just yeah
not go where my head so they visited the
water on tuesday
supergroup
bts visited the white house to talk
about anti-asian discrimination in the
us thank you carine for your kind words
and highway bts and it is a great honor
to be invited to the white house today
to discuss the important issues of
anti-asian hate crimes asian inclusion
and diversity
leonardo and
cloning machines in korea i think so
they're way ahead of us yeah yeah yeah
they they really are great you know lane
speaks green he translated that for me
he means black people please stop
hitting us that's what it means it's uh
it's we don't want to be in front of a
choo choo
so you don't like it
why you don't like me
why why i do dance yeah we all say it's
i mean i can't imagine the singing voice
it's got to be
stop beating the piss out of us yes
please
please stop punching me in the face when
i'm just trying to walk to a taxi
the activists stop handicapping our
s.a.t scores yes please
thanks for killing grandpa
the activism is slightly ironic
considering in korea it is completely
normal to refuse service to someone
because they are a foreigner you guys
know that really wow i thought it was
interesting that they brought them in on
the last day of asian american pacific
islander heritage month were they
touring
maybe they could have been busy who
knows i i just don't yeah would they
just but who found them like you guys
know bts right and everybody in america
is like no and like let's bring them in
[Laughter]
tucker carlson also found the whole deal
a little fishy and had this to say
yeah so we got a korean
pop group to discuss anti-asian hate
crimes in the united states okay good
job guys as noah pollock points out
quote the bi-administration is defending
anti-asian racial discrimination in
university admissions in a case before
the supreme court in case you wanted to
compare substance versus pr
it's not even very good pr
oh right it's the biden administration
that's actively trying to keep asians
out of the ivy league whoa that's right
oops
distraction
but honestly i don't think uh i don't
think tucker understands the power of
bts thankfully i saw this dude at the
time square station
uh was about to push an old korean lady
in front of a train and then dynamite
started playing and now he's
volunteering at a soup kitchen so i
think it's that's a great story it's
important i know absolutely it's a
heartwarming moment well i mean they
also forgot that they took time out of
their busy schedule to go and visit an
old man who's senile in an old folks
home true right yeah nice that's
touching now yeah there's also some
behind the scenes footage where they're
trying to hide uh where they're trying
to
hide biden
making some uh insensitive remarks to
the members of bts i used to stack [ __ ]
like you five feet high in korea use you
for sandbags
[Music]
oh wow you can call them
yes
i'll be here all uh today
i don't know why they keep giving him a
gun that's weird ah every time you hand
him a gun it's just
oh racism
just comes out yeah it really does spots
right just wants them right off their
lawn
shameful there's a lot of reporting on
the visit but uh we wanted to what we
want to do is get to the truth so we
sent out a correspondent laying the
brain to dc to get an interview with one
of the members of bts here is our newest
segment street beats
[Applause]
[Music]
there
jen
j-hope
jimin
rap monster
psy
i'm sorry man there's seven of you all
kind of look like and that's the only
people i know
seriously i mean not like you look alike
but you're all there's seven of you and
you're all dressed like lex freeman so
um i'm francisco longhorn i'm a
podiatrist oh
he's a podiatrist i guess i don't
i'm sorry i love kimchi
so
i mean
i guess that's street beats
[Applause]
[Music]
he went up to over 30 asians and were
the band struck out every single time do
you ever have a korean burger
what's in it kimchi
oh that's pretty much it i've never had
one
no i was honestly curious i've never i
would eat
oh yeah they have a place in vegas it's
like a it's like kpop burger or
something really pretty good i was just
i think more than it's just kimchi on a
burger i'm like kimchi and they put like
french fries in it it's actually a place
okay
that's that's true there is there really
yeah yeah we'll have to have to go check
that out we can't reveal where the
bunker is no but afterwards i need some
uh tips kimchi burger well we can't go
there anymore because it's a aapi
it was
that was yesterday it was yesterday so
it's not we can't go there anymore well
you sold it so well and then you were
like it's just kimchi dave
but then there's fries on it
there's fries on it well you didn't say
that to begin with
so you two should kiss
no yes get over here get over here joe
go over there do it
we all know you want it i'm not doing it
i'll wait till i'm fine
you know it's truer than you know about
biden
he's just run off 21 black staffers from
the white house can you imagine that by
ended really they've left
why would that be
a rough environment to work in at the
white house you ain't black that's
interesting that's what he said to him
in fact and that's why they left it so
how many staff can there be well get
over here boy
there's a lot
but
it's just because he asked every one of
them for shoe shines
domestic staff they're all legal they
want to rub a leg here
sit
just reverting back to old biden that
used to say it all the things out loud
walking around with a chain
he's the only president i well not only
president i'm not at all but let's be
clear
by far but he has said the n-word
unironically so many times on video and
people are like it's fine no no
only eight years ago
his first day he stepped in he was like
man it's like a racial jungle in here
yeah you're like just people it just
brought people the wrong way yeah how
you treat barack and al sharpton it
doesn't matter it's it's the the people
beneath you that's what really matters
and that's we're seeing well of course
he sucks up to barack obama who
completely ignores him now which is
hilarious
well yeah there's a couple of other
people that are leaving the white house
not beneath as in black people are
beneath him
just clarifying well people always show
that made them feel that way yes
well people always show that idea that
when barack said um he'd like to be in a
bunker somewhere just controlling you
yeah you know but it's not like he's
controlling the president it's more like
an episode of impractical joker
[Laughter]
they have the headpiece yeah it's not
it's not doing anything like good with
them there's like wander around the
stage
[Laughter]
now smell that girl go do it yeah you
know you want to come out 83 minutes
late to a press conference
now poop your pants yes right now do it
again take a dump in the vatican yeah
give him the point give him the point he
did it you're in the holy land do it
letterman did it better than anybody
oh he was the best wasn't he there's
nobody better was the guy's name from
next door the uh uh from letterman yeah
who taped next door no no that he would
the guy from the the little uh
was it chris elliott party store next
door he would get these oh the europeans
and do it with him oh i forget the guy's
name those are oh this is great he's got
a new interview show too that's actually
good okay yeah yeah better make it out
yeah yeah still supporting the
beard yeah it's a little weird but he's
still great at what he does there's
really very few like him very few
he was one of the best yeah he is one i
never watched a lot of him sorry you
ever watched a lot of letterman no
that's why you're uh at the end of his
career he became very welcome
yeah yeah that's what i would have seen
him mostly so i'm glad i liked him as
the curmudgeony
sort of uh
just a cynical letterman yeah that's
what made him good
kind of like uh
yeah no he's just letterman
that's just that's about him the bitter
letterman didn't get johnny's seat you
know who's a great comedian that we can
all agree on andy dick
oh yeah where is he now
oh uh well i believe
uh jail um the last name is very
different in a trash can trying to get
eat sandwiches yes yeah i actually did
like him at one point on the ben stiller
show and news radio but
uh a couple weeks ago once again uh the
world renowned uh funny guy and
superstar i want to say andy dick oh
somehow he missed the story and i found
it the other day arrested for sexual
battery at a campsite yeah the whole
thing was caught on live stream yeah
there's no audio he's just getting
frisked and running the paddy wagon he's
enjoying it
this looks like the campsite he didn't
need to be frisked he just requested it
yeah i might have a weapon hidden
because i don't know where it could be
do you have anything sharp on you i have
something hard to ground
that could be anybody we can't say that
yeah
he's doing this thing where he's like
live streaming his entire life at all
times and it's the worst life you could
possibly imagine it's very sad because i
agree with you i think andy dick he's
very funny yeah he was i thought he was
a lot very very funny um but yeah now
it's just sad yeah it is it's really sad
he's like eating literally eating out of
trash cans it's not a joke he did that
and uh just sexually assaulting
everybody yeah i think it's when you
start sexually assaulting everyone yeah
that
it's the sexual battery really no no no
no he's he's bi
oh that's what it is he's the bee
ah oh then he can just do whatever he
wants he gets a pass
he needs help and he's surrounded
himself with
yes men that are like jersey shore type
people that are just like yeah keep
doing this crappy stuff you're doing
right now it's hilarious it's like no
it's sad no we need to go to rehab we
want to fondle our own johnny boy did he
really south by southwest really really
came onto him
oh wait wait
wait there's that's a difference it's
andy dick that's a different level there
could be john goodman who's andy dick
use me johnny johnny g uh
johnny boy yeah funny boy
i'm not came on to him not the
world-renowned actor yeah i like to just
pretend that's his name it's more of a
cupping really but you know yeah more of
a fondle
a cupping he was checking him that's not
it well it even had a roast he just
licked everybody it's like that's not
those aren't jokes it's not funny wait
did you really do that yeah for real
seriously yeah i'm dead seriously he was
never running up to everybody i forgot
what roast it was but he was just
licking them through the entire roast
and you could tell nobody was amused
it's like i don't know where you've been
what are you doing to just slap people
that'll be much more well yeah it's uh
it's a good career ender
it would be good for him he needs to be
done i agree well so you know i think he
is
if you're eating out of trash cans i
think you've hit rock bottom yeah
i mean i hit rock bottom and i barely
ate out of trash cans
though he's in high demand we've
actually uh got a spokesperson on sexual
crimes to come in and do a little psa
for mr dick
[Music]
hi kids
it's me
sexual battery
and i'm here to talk about andy dick's
arrest
he keeps getting arrested for sexual
battery
i don't like the name dick anyway
here you go
don't
insert
cox
without
kindness
no means no
okay
also
andy dick
thank you for giving phil hartman's wife
cocaine
cause now he's dead and we're stuck with
you
wow
i just want to say i'm glad my parents
are dead
um
so are they just patterning years
if i say a little uh not to go behind
the scenes it was supposed to just be a
mascot of a battery costume and then
that came in
well i was like well ramp this up
wardrobe gave me this i guess i'm
wearing it yeah i'm gonna lady it up
although in my days of drinking i would
have definitely hit it
that was reminiscent of the clip we
watched at the beginning of the show it
was wasn't it yeah yeah
i got there for you yeah i got some tips
sick don't insert stop it without
kindness
[Laughter]
one brick of cocaine at a time uh if uh
andy dick phil hartman married a woman
who had a lot of mental health issues
and one of the rules was don't you know
give her drugs all this stuff andy dick
took her out from what we i understand
and uh got her just loaded up on cocaine
and everything wasted and that's when
she went home and shot phil and uh
you know wow
i didn't know that yeah so like john
loves the story right yeah it's the
story everybody likes
allegedly but that's what people at news
radio say john lovitz hates like he's
really like that's pretty much the known
thing now you can't fully blame
him for her drug use and everything else
but
you did do something you shouldn't have
and it ended up in the death of phil
hartman yeah and that's the greatest
comics
comedian actors like
what a loss the greatest asset in the
history of snl because he could do
everything he could be the lead he could
make a sketch better by just being in
the two lines yeah there was nobody in
the background yeah just so he'd be an
extra in sketches and he was great even
like the mad fully down by a river
sketch works because he's playing the
dad so straight and he's one of the few
people that can like hold that scene
while everybody else is just losing
their minds like he was brilliant and so
thank you mr dick
i hope you get your life together i used
to enjoy you on the ben stiller show and
now you're uh eating out of trash cans
speaking of sexual predators
there's more yeah
it's just a [ __ ]
but wait it's a segment but wait is
everywhere
you can get to andy dicks now yes call
right now
uh it's just a shame that this psa is
only coming out now because a former
oklahoma middle school teacher probably
could have benefited from something like
that an arrest warrant has been issued
for 28 year old ivy renew renown renault
renew renault
after she decided to send illicit
messages pictures and videos to a 16
year old look at those yeah yep
renu who was also an assistant soccer
coach met the student at practice and
added him on snapchat after hearing a
rumor that he liked her come on bad deal
strongly you don't do it stop it after
she sent him pictures the student
blackmailed her threatening to ruin her
career whoops well played well i see
what you did there entrepreneur
that's a bold move not exactly the route
i would have gone but
she sent him one hundred and twenty
dollars via cash
that's all you can pay that's [ __ ]
must have all your freedom is worth it
should have gone you're right
we gotta
120 you can't even really get my route
no concept of money's like listen
leave 120 dollars in a dumpster i'll
find it later
but i also still have the nudes so yeah
it's fine foot locker gift certificate
yeah
it's a win-win and cinnabon and dippin
dots it's the ice cream of the future i
would really like to go to lids and pick
out any hat i want
and you can have your career yes by the
way can you drive us i don't have my
license yet no like a game boy color yes
all right different decade yeah i love
it though you still could want one
i don't even know what the kids retro
now i want a p s two slim yeah whatever
that is
what it's a slim ps2 you know what it's
not like the regular name
dang that ain't fat no more
ps2 you've been
since we were dating look at that back
in 0.3
but she was
with the dual shot okay
anyway
but she was already found out because
another teacher overheard the student
telling his friends about the message oh
yeah she overheard the high fives
[Laughter]
although with those with that teacher i
don't know that might not even be a high
five situation well
still
come on we're guys yeah i think i think
everybody here holds pretends you have
higher standards
not when you're 60. yeah when you're 16
i guess it's anywhere
anything when you're sick the standard
is yes yes that's it yeah really she's
so wait she's a
middle school teacher and he's 16. oh
well middle school i think goes to
different grade levels no i don't think
so what's going on here i think it's
good he held back
no i guess that's true he maybe he's
some sort of street tough
yeah he's got a leather jacket yeah back
hair like grease they all look like
they're 30.
he was a little scholarship
hey
it's like it always picks this just the
coolest special needs student in school
just smoking
let's get one of those helmets on yeah
those soft head helmets it's the coolest
jacket but it's one of those mohawk
helmets
[Laughter]
open down the middle like who are those
guys i hear they're well honey
like a peppa mill that kid all right
explains a lot i know right
but as
and that's the route i would have taken
though bragging to my friends honestly
okay okay kids kids haven't changed that
much yeah but come on man this is wrong
yeah i know oh
yeah all kidding aside it's nice to see
a woman reaching for equality in the
teacher sex predator racket
for a while there was just dudes who
were the pervy and morally bankrupt
i didn't write that in it's pretty much
in women doing it i got to be honest
yeah i think in teachers
section i think it's all women i'll be
honest i do use a prompter sometimes
i didn't write that in
women are pretty much the ones going for
the male students and i wa like what the
hell when i was a come on
i would have
so to be perfectly clear dave is saying
that he would have accepted her
yeah i would have and you're vulnerable
yeah what it's adolescent mind yeah but
i would told everybody and then when the
police asked i would have been like no
man
i don't know what you're talking back
then there was even a merit badge and
scouting i think there was yeah that was
the don't tell your parents back but it
was a totally different kind of sex yeah
this time it's like don't tell your
parents what we did
now unfortunately take your kids out of
public school if you could if you could
get out of a knot they would take a
badge away from you yeah by the way it's
it it is bad it's wrong it's illegal it
should be illegal obviously that but if
you understood what was going on in the
mind of a 16 year old boy you would see
this very differently i can't they're
very vulnerable
i'm just no i'm not they're not
vulnerable no they're totally vulnerable
16 years because of their mind they're
very vulnerable very easily swayed into
sex
show a picture of a lug wrench to a 16
year old boy and he'll think about sex
okay like which end do you want it on
that lug bridge you don't even need pull
you could draw it
yeah
dave not everybody's gifted no all you
need is a calculator yeah it's flip it
upside down man done that doesn't do it
you don't lie does it appear if you
haven't every person in here when you
first get that dose of testosterone the
devil's nectar
you can't help it in school you're just
like why
why
why
everybody i see
i think everybody had a teacher growing
up of course yeah oh i miss you lean
over to check your work yeah you're
usually a student teacher or a subject a
couple of bees
your boobs are huge
everybody had a huge teacher though
right yeah ours was a math teacher and a
gymnast oh and her name was mrs romaine
yes we had
salad named after the lettuce
i'm glad i covered that up exotic
almost
[Laughter]
she was very pretty i don't know if
she's still married yeah i don't know
we'll find out
you know i call her i don't know she's
probably
haggard now
rough we're watching this and like
thanks dave thanks a lot i didn't even
know you were in my class you came in
twice and smelled like pot a little
bastard yeah she's also a man now so
yeah that's probably true
we had oh we had a real this roman we
had a huge
one teacher
know what very large lady that's a huge
[ __ ] yeah
huge heart i meant huge which is
probably why she died now anyway so the
uvalde police interview yesterday i want
to get into this guys i know it's a
little bit serious but i think it's
important uh that we have to bring this
up
the uvolde police department they are no
longer cooperating with the texas
department of public safety's
investigation
this comes after dps director
stephen mcgraw called out the school
district's police chief pete
aaron aaron dondo is that correct
eredando yeah for making the wrong
decision by delaying entry to the
classroom and that the delay was against
protocol yeah and to be clear he's
refusing
or has refused to respond to an
interview request and that's what we're
mostly talking about right now okay well
chief chief eridando failed uh yeah to
respond to our request
well yeah which is why but we were able
to get the interim chief and we do
believe that they should be
you know here to tell their side uh so
please welcome one of the officers that
was on scene officer
hugh japusi
[Music]
uh hello uh huge a [ __ ] now you're on
how are you
oh uh i'm great uh one of your employees
wouldn't let me in so i'm sorry uh we
yeah we tried to buzz you in almost an
hour ago there's uh footage from our
ring camera
uh no there's not
yeah there there is there's a there's an
hour of you smoking and scrolling
through tick-tock
oh my god well we have protocols to
follow in these types of situations
i don't think you do it's an interview
easy for you to say civilian
you're not in the military in fact i
think you have a disqualifying condition
you're a huge vagina
true but it's better that i am safe and
sorry can't be too careful what that's
not how it goes no no what so wait so
that's why you didn't take the shooter
down faster because you wanted to
protect yourself darn tootin
really it's your job to protect and
serve it's my job to serve the public
interest meet quotas with arbitrary
traffic tickets and to stop people from
getting haircuts
stuff like that
you know i think we're just about done
here oh is that a spider
oh my gosh
whoa what oh
if only a teacher had left that door
propped open so i could escape oh just
pull harder
you twist the handle
open it up do it do a workout or
something
dave you're a lifesaver yeah you're
[Music]
not maybe it's this time of the month i
don't know i think so
huge a [ __ ] everybody
[Music]
i thought we told people not to smoke in
here
uh i i don't tell huge a [ __ ] what to
do i grew up with cigarettes so it's a
little reminder of why i'm only five six
yeah um
right yeah i just want to say though we
do i do realize that that is not um i
just want to say it says honestly as i
can uh i do realize that is not all
police this is a very different and
delicate situation but uh to make any
light of it i did want to address ken up
as a vagina
[Laughter]
and we looked for an excuse and found
one yeah the only way well the only way
that i can really get through anything
like that or anybody can is to me is to
obviously make make uh light of darkness
and i'm very uh sorry for everything
going on but the fact that 19 people
were not able to do what one man did i
think is
tragic and that has nothing to do with
every other officer in the country who i
believe most would have done
yeah anything yeah i don't know how it
happened that it didn't but i i think
that
any other police outside of there taking
crap forward is not right just my
opinion well that one guy that needs to
take crap forward is the guy who was in
charge at the scene and he's no longer
taking questions from anybody or
cooperating as of this moment now that
may change he was the one that told them
to to stand down this is a hostage
situation no no no he's just barricaded
in a room nobody else is in there and
there were obviously people still in
there alive so yeah um terrible idea
there were 19 police officers that
you're referring to in the next room
correct or in that hallway area they've
shown now
um ready to go and we're told to wait
yes so the minute there's a shot it's an
active shooter protocol absolutely
actually it doesn't matter if he goes in
barricades after that right is the he
could have one person in there he could
have a hundred he could have you have no
idea how many people are stuck in that
room because it's a chaotic situation
right so it's mind-boggling one thing i
do want to clear up though is that
we we have been given information just
like the rest of the world that has
changed right so they said that a
resource officer confronted the shooter
that didn't happen there was a number of
other things that they've talked about
the timeline that just were a little bit
weird trying to get the information
correctly that was the biggest
incident but now we also know we've
talked about something very very i made
a huge point about this yesterday is
that the door was left open by a teacher
prior to the gunman going in we had
video footage of that she did prop the
door open with a rock but when she ran
back inside to grab her phone to call
9-1-1 she came back and saw
uh the gunman i don't know if she saw
the gun but she did hear guys from
across the street saying that he had a
gun
she kicks the rock out from the door
and slams the door but it doesn't lock
right and so um there was actually a
quote here and and i just wanted to read
that because i made a huge deal out of
that because i was very pissed off about
somebody leaving a door propped open and
leading to potentially a very chaotic
terrible event i don't know he may have
gotten in any way outside of that but
she tried and that's right and she in a
moment of panic i'd say that she did
more than a lot of people she did more
than that and honestly if we had known
the identity of this person i don't
think it's out there and i'm so glad
it's not because there's no time the
last week of her life would have been
hell because everybody would have been
saying this person
is the reason along with maybe a couple
of other people that they're trying to
blame for this these people are the
reason it was this bad the police chief
takes some responsibility obviously he
was in charge of the situation right so
you can point the finger at him and say
he he screwed up i almost said the other
word whoa he messed up right with her
people were saying why did you leave the
door propped open and that was probably
something that was going to just destroy
her life for a minute because people
wouldn't come back and read the
correction right and so one of the the
quotes there is that from the texas dps
is that we did verify she closed the
door the door did not lock we know that
much and now investigators are trying to
look into why the door didn't lock
so a little bit more information coming
up i don't think we're really going to
ever know
fully what happened until we get a
complete investigation i know that
sounds redundant but
there's just been so much that they've
said happened that didn't happen or that
they were a little bit off by yeah i
don't i don't think you're wrong i don't
think saying it's redundant i mean of
course a complete investigation would
reveal everything that we could probably
find out so well everything is so lined
with misinformation now that we find out
new stuff every single day yeah every
single second really so
you know we heard that about the teacher
we heard
we've heard uh that about the person who
tried to stop him in the hallway we
heard you know
we i didn't know 19 police officers were
in the school yeah i mean there's so
many different things that were going on
whatever happened this should be
the
the biggest blueprint to make sure a
tragedy like this never happens again
whatever we decide as a nation
yeah well and it was fresh training too
that they had received on active shooter
situations eight weeks prior
and so they really need to take a hard
look at that training and say well this
this didn't work in this situation and
that's not to point fingers in place
blame that's to make sure that it does
in the future
and there's a lot of proposals out there
right now that would absolutely do
nothing to help solve this situation so
they need to make sure they focus on the
right things by the way there's one
other thing chief
arredondo actually was sworn in as a
city council member in ivalde yesterday
in a kind of a secret ceremony not
secret to keep it from being known but
secret because it just there was no need
to have kind of any pageantry or
ceremony he was he was elected to city i
think there was other seasons yeah
he was a baby yeah elected to city
council earlier in the month and this is
just
obviously i think maybe you postpone
that i think just in light of recent
events maybe there's some kind of
mechanism where they can say
maybe not you know yeah they might isn't
the post for you yeah there's several
reasons you might want to
re-vote yeah
wow and he's getting a lot of flack
right now look he's
i can't imagine being that person no
it's got to be very hard that's his job
this is going to weigh in
you're right this this defines the rest
of your life for sure and it will not be
the only these will not be the only
deaths as a result of it i hate to say
it but this will there's already been
one additional the man who died of a i
guess a heart attack um after his wife
was killed there within a couple of days
i can't remember exactly wow
i can't imagine the stress but i can't
imagine if you're if you're a police
chief you should be expecting this type
of scenario every single day and be
ready for that right it's your job to
you're the chief
it's your job to take care of stuff like
this does anybody remember ever seeing a
swat team there ever no no i didn't see
any any black uh
uniforms no i didn't either so they
never arrived there was never any
special no there was a special border
patrol team i think that they were
potentially waiting for or that ended up
showing up that it was only three people
but
i i don't know man i i see
i see him in that position and
garrett your point is right that is
absolutely 100 his job and i i hate it
because you're seeing a person there
right who made a bad decision in the
heat of the moment but that's that's
exactly why they're in that position and
if you can't do that
that's fine just go do something else
don't put yourself in a position to have
to be the guy to make the right call in
an active shooter situation if you can't
do it
right this isn't just going collecting a
check and riding around and glad handing
the the locals this is when things go
down they're going to count on me to
make the right decision and i didn't
tim well he's he's got his backup gig
now city council yeah yeah he's set i
don't think i'll win re-election though
i'm betting it's a single term
yeah yeah
it's just sad because i think so many
like we all pay taxes we all have to do
that and then we send out police
officers to just get you know money for
the state and traffic tickets which is
nonsense it's not fair to them it's not
fair to us i mean i understand you have
to stop highway fatalities and duis and
all that other stuff because you know
there are pelosi's out there
[Laughter]
but sincerely like that sucks and if we
focused more on actually to serve and
protect and less on making them do a
bunch of bs i think that more of this
would be avoidable
if everything wasn't about a cash game
it would be avoidable yeah yeah and if
we didn't make knee-jerk reactions
that i think this these 100 a lot of
things all these policies that we put in
place after these events that happen um
i think are a lot of times misguided
well
and with the last two years with the
wonderful amount of respect people have
had for officers oh yes and everything
else you know it's back the blue has
been the mantra yes of course it's like
okay you got a
a young hispanic male okay well what
what do i do you know it's it it's
terrifying now and
we there just has to be some kind of
change to all of this if we want to
protect our children yeah a business
what a massive
massive show of like why you should
protect yourself why you should carry
why you should train yeah why you should
prepare for situations because the
police
are not always going to do the right
thing yeah well and it happens it's not
going to happen as well right remember
the the police officer at parkland who
didn't go in right it was on the scene
and could have potentially saved lives i
mean
this is that was just one guy i know
this one guy i'm saying this is worse
but you know you've got you've got
instances where this happens and when
there's no protection in these places
there's zero people people always use
you know churches as soft targets
targets too and i'm like yeah most of
the time there are armed police officers
and plain clothes in those churches do
you know why
because they need to be ready if
something goes down because they know
it's a soft target most people aren't
going to be carrying to church unless
you're in like rural west texas or
something like that and then i love it
right yeah good luck you're not going to
get very far with those guys or me in
mind yeah yeah yeah yeah no i'm just
saying like when a country loses god
that's what you get of course
and i think that's the biggest thing
that we we tend not to focus on is that
there are evil people in the world
yeah how many people i've seen it's an
object that's the problem and it's not
the object it's the people wielding the
object how many people i've seen this
time go don't talk about mental health
this time like i'm sick of hearing that
that is the issue of course the issue is
mental health and we're not thinking
about that at all like we just saw in
2020
none of that was taken into
consideration
none of it whenever we made all these
sweeping changes to our society
mental health is why this is happening
and like you just said you took
a great barometer of what you should be
doing morally you took god out of
everything and
yeah this is what you get do what feels
good oh what happens when you can't find
anything that feels good right well
you're gonna go find then what do you
want to do you're taking someone who i
would love to meet as a 15 year old kid
three years ago before all this stuff
happened and an 18 year old mass shooter
now i'd love to see the difference of
what the last few years
like the tournament that took on him
alone yeah i'd like to know what he was
watching see his history yeah what he
was doing what led him to this
like you know he was a kid too and i'm
no i'm not excusing him no but what
changed him yeah he was a human being
what made him snap yeah what got him 16
in 2020 yeah so what does that tell you
what it is what happened sort of an
influential age wouldn't you say
interesting to see so no father in the
home mom was on drugs
living with grandma you think slight
abandonment issues maybe then locked at
home yeah made to feel worthless no
father at home
i mean there's so many of these things
that we the media just don't touch again
it's guns it's guns it's guns yeah well
hold on let's look at what makes these
people do this
and i'm not saying it excuses but at
least steven said this the other day on
the show it's the low-hanging fruit
right go for the things that can have
the best result now it's like biden
saying well i'm going to give clean
energy credits okay maybe in 10 years
then we'll have the problem solved but
between now and then it's going to be
hell and gas prices are going to be
really high in the economy is going to
suck because you just got a second thank
you yeah that's fantastic i've had a
solar watch since 88.
[Laughter]
we haven't improved a whole heck of a
lot right but we don't look at the
things that could actually prevent this
and say look until we get a better grip
on the policies that will help make
changes in society how about we just
make sure that there are people armed at
the campus so if somebody wants to come
there and do harm they will have bullets
flying at them for a change instead of
kids dodging them in the hallway and
throwing cell phones maybe that's a
better idea and and that's what i've
said and it's it's and i don't know if
there's any validity to this and a lot
of people may disagree don't get all mad
but if alcohol and tobacco are 21 is
there a way to have it where your dad
goes in with you when you're 18. is
there a way to maybe add that to it or
you have to be in the military some sort
of other level of responsibility or if
an 18 year old kid comes in who doesn't
seem balanced
is there like you don't have to sell
them the handgun right or the uh shotgun
or the rifle whatever yeah maybe i'm
just saying like is there actually a
sensible gun law that can be made that
isn't just this extremist view every
single time i think people would be
willing to have that conversation
especially how immature 18 year olds are
that's my point now maybe that's exactly
now yes absolutely fine and i'm not
saying one way or the other no i'm not
saying you should but i'm just throwing
out an idea that's not insane yeah you
have to be able to talk about it without
going we're taking all of your guns
which is what democrats want to do let's
just be very clear i think that's why
people get nervous
democrats want to take all of your guns
and so that's why most people are like i
don't want to talk to you because i know
exactly where you're going to go well
most people are just looking for
something that makes sense not taking
away the second amendment
that's what most people want but you
can't even have that conversation dave
like you're saying because they'll go oh
well you just think there should be
other rules and then eventually it's
just going to be taking away guns and
it's like no look no maybe kids
darren i don't know if you had this but
i've heard a lot of people say that kids
used to have guns in their pickup truck
on gun racks back in the 60s and 50s at
schools and we we had no or very few
mass shootings ever in schools well to
say that's the eight boxes eighties you
had that
yeah my my parents i mean it was west
texas no but that's that's true
but they had guns in there in the cabs
of their trucks that was like a normal
thing yeah nobody ever shot anybody yeah
there's something different between them
any rural parts of the country really
yeah you know there's something and you
know what's interesting is more rural
parts are more
god-fearing they have more moral
compasses not to say everybody in those
areas are all perfect people but there
is a sense of moral
you know there is an idea of what
everybody should do and how everybody
should treat each other and stuff like
that and like
a base for everybody's belief yeah they
have family there's something about the
kind of roar rural that's a hard [ __ ]
word
[Laughter]
you're more tight-knit no there's not
it's not strangers around you so you do
care
yeah and we've lost all of it in urban
areas but when i was a kid in detroit
only the criminals had guns if you you
had to prove that you were a business
owner and you transported large sums of
cash right where you could carry just
between the bank and your shop that was
it yeah so
all the thugs had the guns that's insane
yeah yeah there was also pre-internet
that's true yeah but when you get out
into the rural parts of the state you
know people had in their trucks well i
think that's part of the issue is the
internet has caused an immaturity you
know i mean there's there's certainly a
difference i think between an 18 year
old
even of my age and i'm 40 next week like
you know versus hey happy early birthday
yeah i can't wait
yeah yeah every way to the grave it's
dave
all right so halfway
well right more
well look one of the best ways to deal
with i'm sure though they're only going
to dig three feet
very nice not as much work
one of the one of the best ways to deal
with tragedy and dave you've helped me
see this a little bit more because you
have some you take some dark situations
and you make them funny right yeah
that's right laughter you can either and
there's a range of emotions but you can
most of the time it's you can cry or you
can laugh absolutely that's why people
will break out in laughter at a funeral
when somebody says something even mildly
funny because it's a way to release that
built up kind of emotion and so um i
know you know comedians are still going
out on the road and we talked about your
date in june 17th but you've got another
one coming up as well i do uh june 10
and 11 at the funny bone in des moines
iowa des moines yes des moines my buddy
derek richards will be on the show and i
hope you guys come out i like des moines
there's a corn and oh
huh corn i believe they make it into
gasoline
ethanol yeah there's all sorts all sorts
of stuff you do with corn there
squirrels can eat it
corn syrup and everything corn bob
creole corn
imagine how much corn on the cob
bubba corn shrimp company
why did i throw in shrimp
it's still also shrimp yeah corn shrimp
corn shrimp
grill shrimp
well thank you all for listening i
appreciate uh everybody for coming in we
are going to go into mug club right now
do we have a little game or what do we
got oh yeah we're going to go reddit
rabbit hole oh before we leave though i
want to tell everybody the show that i'm
doing friday night tights on the nerd
roddick channel yes yes we're having
alex jones on our 200th episode this
friday are you going to talk about all
the things he's gotten right that
sounded ludicrous when he said them
we're going to we're going to see what
happens so it's going to be crazy that's
fantastic nerd roddick where does he get
nerd radical that's what you call it
nostradamus is he coming by helicopter
hopefully yeah hopefully that'd be the
best way for somebody who just filed for
bankruptcy to travel yeah
efficient efficient i think it's a joke
it's protection relax everyone it's
pretty no that's really cool yes that's
an awesome game hopefully come watch
it's gonna be fun yeah check that out on
fridays what time
it is at 3 00 p.m central standard time
and hello friday afternoon oh we go for
like four hours yeah you guys do a long
time yeah good show yeah
why four hours because it's fun
why why wouldn't you do four why not
i'll try i'm there soon too so yeah
i'm no i'm no aj
but i'm dl
piss off youtube